artists staged a mass protest against AI
there's a strike taking place on the
platform art station normally here you
would see the work of artists but in
recent times the landing page of the
platform has been filled with the same
image calling for a ban of AI on the
platform and the deletion of any artwork
created with the help of AI artists want
to draw attention to the fact that
artificial intelligence is violating
copyrights because it's trained using
already completed works by living
artists and AI then mixes them modifies
them and passes them off as its own an
extensive debate unfolded on social
media around the question is AI stealing
art art station quickly reacted to the
artist's revolt and introduced the tag
no AI if an artist tags their projects
with this tag AI won't be able to use
their work is it really just the problem
of copyrights or have artists become
concerned that AO will take work away
from them that is a perfect copy after
all up until recently AI artworks looked
like this and now they look like this
will AI become an assistant for artists
or will it be able to replace them